all right Ted well there is a potential
schedule change for Clark County Schools
CCSD and the Clark County Education
Association both talking about
negotiations over teacher pay the
district saying the Union's demands are
to blame as they negotiate contract
agreements Sasha loft is speaking with
parents about this she joins us live at
CCSD headquarters tonight
our County School District she believes
a change like this wouldn't just impact
students but the families working to get
them to class
adjusting any school times is going to
be hugely effective CCSD parent Anna
Marie binder reacts to a potential
change this coming school year there's a
lot of families that don't have help you
know we're a very transient town on
Wednesday the district said it's
adjusting the start and end times of 47
schools many in underserved parts of
Southern Nevada blaming recent Union
demands here's how the back and forth
breaks down Clark County Education
Association is pushing for a bump in
teacher pay after 250 million dollars
was allocated for raises at the Nevada
legislature but CCSD says what they're
asking for in the
2023-2025 negotiations is quote
unreasonable citing what they call
exhaustive attempts to come to an
agreement over several months teachers
want to be paid they want to be paid
what they're worth binder wants to see
teachers get what they're asking for
while kids maintain their best
educational opportunities our children
are not ponds and our educators are not
pawns and with less than a month left
before the first school bell binder adds
that she and other parents hope some
sort of agreement is reached soon a lot
of parents obviously rely on school to
have a place for their children for six
hours a day
now the district also made public two
proposals that they gave to CCSD they
say that included a potential increase
in salaries the most recent dated June
16th now they say administrators of
those schools impacted will be sending
out messages to parents about the
changes reporting live tonight Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now